this agenda is on inheritance why do we
need inheritance
what is inheritance components of
inheritance the extend keyword access
modifiers super keyword types of
inheritance the diamond problem is a
relation and has a relation what is
inheritance there are two other key
terms which are not going to be in this
agenda but you should also when you get
to them make sure you bundle them
together as you're understanding these
structures and that's the abstract class
and the polymorphism so what is
inheritance inheritance is an act
through which a new class gets created
by acquiring the variables and methods
defined in the previous parent class so
we look at what is inheritance we can
take an example of say food we have
veggies noodles fruits where food is the
parent and your veggies your noodles and
fruits are all subclasses of that
they're all kind of children of food why
do we need inheritance we implement
inheritance for a multiple of reasons
like creating a possibility to add or
remove features to reduce the code
length as we reuse a code more
comfortable to develop and maintain the
project and so if we start looking at
let's say we have a cell phone we make
calls we have our SMS texting or
communication on our phone we have our
media we also had a browser on there so
now we have a smart phone and we look at
that we have our phone set up and then
we have our full smart phone media call
SMS and browser
and we start to kind of link these
instead of making them separate we can
have the call and the text and then we
can have them inherit we can actually
create a media that inherits their
quality so now you can text your media
now you can use the browser as part of
your call scenario and I would even add
one more example in here and that is
that all programming languages that are
object base are built on inheritance
Java Python C++ so this concept of
building an object and then that object
then is inherited by everything
underneath of it is important to
understand even then these most even as
we're looking at more specific cases
so we'll take a look at the components
of inheritance and the most important
two components in inheritance the two
major components that are mentioned our
parent class or the superclass in the
child class or the sub class and to see
this let's go ahead and jump into
eclipse and take a look at what the
actual code looks like so the first
thing I want to do is go ahead and add
in a new package and we're gonna go
ahead and call this package inheritance
that's what we're working with
oops give me a default Java tutorial in
their inheritance finish and I started
off with the Java tutorials just a went
in and created a new project and made
sure it was Java based so we have our
packaged inheritance right here we're
going to go ahead and add in a new class
and we'll go ahead and call this class
machine now one of the standards when
you're creating classes to capitalize
the first letter so always remember to
do that in some places people like to
have the whole word capitalized it
really depends on who you're working
with but it is kind of if it starts with
a capital letter it's probably a class
and so once we have our inheritance we
have our public class machine let's go
ahead and give it a little bit
underneath there to do something and
we'll start with protected string brand
and so whatever machine we're working
with these particular machines are going
to be will call them Santa it'll be a
Samsung free they get some free vocab
free marketing right there for Samsung
so Samsung machines and then we want to
do something so let's go ahead and put a
procedure in there and we'll make it
public void does not gonna return
anything and we'll call this a wash I
guess they're all wash machines there we
go there's our brackets a little trouble
finding the bracket on there and let's
just have it during this we'll just have
it do a quick print line and we'll say
initiating cycle there and of course our
semicolon on the end alright so now we
have a public class machine and we're
gonna get into when we start working
with the actual inheritance you can
create an object with this machine we
haven't done anything special to it it's
like any other class you might create in
the java language and we've added in
public void wash a procedure with no
return us with the void means and it's
gonna print out and so let's go ahead
and create another class in here new
class and this one's gonna be washing
machine washing machine and we'll go
ahead and hit finish on here and we come
into our washing machine let's opened up
a nice new tab for us and we might have
a private string model name we'll change
this to model type model type equals so
the type of machine is is a top-load
washing machine
so we have a samsung as a main type of
machines we're looking at we have top
loader or a top loading washing machine
and then we're going to add up here
extends machine and so this is the the
key code we're gonna look for because we
want this to have the properties of the
machine so this comes in and says
whatever is in machine we now also have
in our washing machine and then of
course if you're gonna do all this we
need to actually be able to run it and
if we're gonna do that we want to go
ahead and add in the public static void
main reserved keywords there and this is
just your standard main startup your
string of arguments there we go
and of course our bracket and then in
here we're gonna take and create a
washing machine object and so here's our
wash machine that's of course the type
washing machine and it's going to equal
a new washing machines or initiating a
new object in here there we go and then
we want to do something and if we're
gonna have it do something we wanted to
go ahead let's see what happens we have
wash member our keyword up there was
washing machine dot wash and where did
that come from well if you go back into
machine here it is public void wash
there's the procedure and it's coming
into the washing machine and this is
inherited that way we don't have to
retype that every time we have a washing
machine this can be washing machine
maybe the next one is I don't know but
different kind of washing machines I'm
not an expert on washing machines we
have to do a wash and then specific to
the washing machine in here we also had
the type and so we can go back up here
or brand so we can come up down here we
can go system
dot print line wash machine dot brand
plus a little dash in there plus and
then we're going to go ahead and we have
our wash machine dot model type that
model type we put in there so the brand
where does the brand come from the
brands coming from our machine we have
our protective string which is going to
be Samsung and then we have our washing
machine which has the model type which
is a top-load machine and if we go ahead
and run this after of course we make
Korea that semicolon in on the end there
we come up there we'll see initiating
cycle initiating cycle is printed out
from machine and then the Samsung top
load washing machine is the second print
out line here and so when we have our
wash print out here also though get wash
machine wash is initiating cycle and
then we had that's where that printout
comes from we can go back up here to
machine you can see right here
initiating cycle then we flip back over
to the washing machine we print out wash
machine dot brand which is the machine
class and then wash machine model type
which is underneath the washing machine
so let's go over all that let's take a
look and see what we're talking about
here so we saw on the code the extends
keyword the term extends is a pretty
defined keyword in Java that allows you
to create a new child class by deriving
the variables and methods from the
parent class to reduce code links and
improve the performance and we see that
right up here in our public class
washing machine extends machine so the
next key thing to talk about is access
modifiers and I kind of breezed over
them when I put together the code but
we'll dig in there little deeper we
talked about access modifiers there is
four different
words you really need to know and that's
default public protected and private and
I'm going to tell you right now default
equals public so what is default default
access modifier is set implicitly
whenever you declare a class without a
specific access modifier by default the
access of a class or method when
declared without a specific access
modifier becomes available to any other
method or class within the same package
and in Java the default is public so
public a certain class can be declared
as public by using the keyword public
any class or method when declared as
public
becomes available to any class or method
declared in the same package but if a
different method or class needs it it
should be imported
and then we have protected a certain
classes declared protected by using the
keyword protected this provides access
to the methods and variables of the
protected class only to the rightful
subclasses and protects the data from
any other classes which are not related
and then private a certain class is
declared protected by using the keyword
private this provides the ultimate
protection to the data members and the
methods of the private class this
procedure is implemented by class to
encapsulate the method and members so
will take a little work so gonna do a
different example in here but I do like
this underneath the washing machine you
can see right here we have put in
private a private string what this means
is that only washing machine can access
that private string where if you have
protected the children can access it so
protect the screen if you're underneath
a machine up here we have protected so
that when I create the washing machine
and extend machine I can still access it
but if I create a sub class of washing
machine on a market is private that sub
class is not going to be able to access
it and so it has to do with what layers
of accessing think of this is a big team
project you create something do you
really want that to cascade down to the
next class or who do you want to have
access to that lets go a little deeper
to really bring this home because it's
really important to understand this
terminology let's go ahead and start a
new class here and we're just gonna call
this particular class summation yeah I'm
go ahead and create that finish and so
our summation class it's going to be
pretty simple in here we'll go ahead and
do public so anything buddy can access
it just remember here's our public on
there and then we'll just do a into
jerks that's what it's going to return
as an integer we're going to call it add
and we're going to put integer X comma
integer Y
and it will just return X plus y so real
simple we're just adding two numbers
here's our two inputs that both have to
be integers and we're going to return an
integer and it'll be the summation of
the two so a real simple class right
there and if we're going to have a
summation then let's go ahead and create
a new class we'll call this one child
and in our new child class we're going
to go ahead and keep this simple and
we're just going to have our public
static main we're gonna have our
summation a equals new summation and
then system.out.print line a dot add 100
plus 200 pretty straightforward
everything's public in here it's okay
there's our running and we see that it
answer is 300 so this is public if you
remember quickly we're talking about
public and so when we use a public
keyword any class or method when
declared as public becomes available to
any class or method declared in the same
package but if in a different method or
class needs it it should be imported so
here we go it's that's our public setup
it's just open to everybody well
everybody that's under the package
inheritance so somewhat whoever is using
that package can now use the this
particular child and let's go ahead and
add a new class in and this time we're
gonna do a parent class I'll just put
that right in there and we come in with
our parent class you can see right here
the parent class itself is public but we
want to do underneath the parent class
is we want to create a protected void
because we're not returning anything and
print so we're gonna do the print there
and this protected print that's going to
put our brackets in there and we'll do
just a simple print line hello world and
once we have that print hello world we
want to go ahead and add a child class
to this and let's see we already well we
had the child class when it took it out
a second ago so we'll go ahead and put
that back in here's our child class
and before this child of class we want
it to go ahead and extend the parent so
inheritance there's our extend on there
oops let me type that all right extend
this parent so now the Chuck class is
part of the parent class and we'll go
ahead and put our main in there so that
it'll run it and execute it and we'll
create our child X equals new child
class go ahead and sign our variable X
in Ischia tit and then we'll do just the
print and see what happens here so
here's our print statement and we'll go
ahead and run this and compile our child
on there and when it comes in there you
see it says print hello world and so the
parent has marked this as protected so
it's protected from objects that are not
inheriting it but the child can still
access that information and print it on
there
so here's protected this provides access
to methods and variables of the
protected class only to the rightful
subclasses and protects the data from
any other classes which are not related
and a lot of programming that's usually
where you end up is doing a lot of stuff
that is underneath your parent did is
protect it you either make them public
or protected a lot of people are sloppy
and just make them public but most of
stuff you want to make sure it's
protected and then we finally have our
private and I'm gonna go back here to
our child and we're gonna run this and
it's going to come up and say proceed
with launch errors in setup and then
it's going to give us an exception
thread main compilation error the method
print from the type parent is not
visible and that's because unless you
actually initiate the parent you're not
going to see this code because it's
private it's only private to the public
to the parent class so even if I extend
it in child it will not be available and
that again protects it that means it's
something that you don't want to inherit
and cascade down because maybe it is a
piece of code that is gonna be changed
and so you don't want all the children
to crash ever
time to make a change to it so with
private this provides the ultimate
protection to the data members in the
methods of the private class this
procedure is implemented by class to
encapsulate the methods and members so
very important we have private and we
have protected and we have public the
more access to you one of the pieces of
the software code to have and other
programmers they have the more public
you want to make it and of course the
default is public now one of the common
workarounds for this because you're
going to have protected data but you
still want it to be used by the
subclasses it is to create what they
call like a get or a and we'll do it up
here
we'll go ahead and do a private integer
X equals five and then instead of on
your inheritance instead of having it
call it from the child we might have a
get thing or a get thing we might have a
public gonna return an integer and we
might have it say get X and this simply
just return X and what this means is
that we have something simple like this
or it just does a return X I can go back
into my child here and instead of print
X will do X dot get X and we'll go ahead
and print this out or you know something
simple with that we'll go ahead and do a
system print line on this and when we
run this you'll see it come up it's
going to recompile then we get our five
what's happening here is now I've
created underneath the parent private
information you don't know what's going
on with it it's protected you might have
a procedure that's protected in this
case we had the print procedure and then
we access it from the public and this
could have easily have been instead of
maybe we'll just call it public
avoid public print kind of a goofy way
of doing the code there we go
and then it could go in here and access
our print and so we can actually still
access this print variable up here by
wrapping it in kind of a get or a public
function this allows us to protect
whatever code is going on in the parent
class so it can't be messed up it can't
be accessed indirectly it has to go
through the right processes and so when
we get to the child on here the child
can then still has the public processes
but all the other information isn't is
protected it is private it's really
important to remember that private right
there this brings us to super keyword
and we talk about the super keyword
super keyword eliminates the confusion
between parent class method and sub
class method super keyword is
implemented to access a method or
constructor that is defined in the
parent class so back in eclipse will go
under parent and we'll take this we're
gonna take the private out of there so
now we have an integer five and we'll go
ahead and just remove the print because
we're not going to do that in the parent
oops and the public there we go and so
let's create a parent that just has one
piece of information it has an integer X
equals five and then we're gonna go to
the child and let's go ahead and add in
here integer x equals ten and these are
by default they're public we haven't
said anything on here telling it what it
is and so what I'd like to do is we'd
like to go ahead and create a whoops one
more thing there we go
create a procedure here and we'll just
call this void capital print and it's
just going to be a system.out.print line
and this is what I want you to notice is
we're gonna print out X and super X
so we have the child class X and we have
the parent class super X and if we come
down here and we do X dot print don't
forget my semicolon at a couple spaces
in here to make it look nicer when we
print it and we'll go ahead and run this
and you can see that the child class
prints 10 and the parent class is 5 and
so this way you can actually store
different information depending on what
it is you're working on and what you're
doing and that's where the super comes
in you can see right here where the
super underneath the class and the print
module now you can't just put it in down
here under print let me explore what
that looks like if I just take this and
I go ahead and highlight it and let's
say I wanted to just instead of doing X
print it's gonna come up right here and
right off the bat you see the super dot
X I can do X dot super dot X and it's
still going to give me an error right
here it has to be underneath a procedure
in the actual class and not under the
main this brings us to types of
inheritance and there's four main types
we have single inheritance which we've
already pretty much looked at but we'll
go back over we have multi-level
inheritance we have hierarchical
inheritance and hybrid inheritance let's
go and just start with the single
inheritance single inheritance consists
of one parent class and one child class
here child class inherits parent class
methods and data members and let's go
ahead and create a new class up here
just to change it up and keep it
interesting new class and we'll call
this one student and under the student
will have a simple set up we'll just do
an enrolled and I'll say enrolled in
simply learn there we go so there's our
class student and then we'll create
another class we'll do it as a because
we have our student or base student and
then we'll call this one
ooh class I will call this one computers
there we go
so he's a rolled finish and for
computers let's go ahead and put in a
print line here and we'll put down
studying computers and we want to go
ahead and do the extends extends student
so it's a student studying computer
subclass computers and this would all
look familiar because we've been doing
this for you know a lot of the other
setups this is your basic inheritance
and we'll change that from enrolled to
studies and then let's go ahead and put
a main in here so we can actually run it
and we have our p enrolled which comes
from our parent class and our p studies
which comes from the child or the one
that inheritance hit the extends for
student and let's go ahead and run that
there we go run and you can say enrolled
and simply learn studying computers and
then we can go on to the next setup and
this is where we look at multi-level
inheritance is also a parent-child
inheritance relation but the difference
is the child class is inherited by
another child class this is the basic
structure of most programming languages
right here you have an object you have
all the different things under the
object and it gets all the way down to
whether it's an array you're working
with whether even a class is a sub child
that goes all the way up to the object
and we can simply do that in our code in
Eclipse and we'll just go ahead and add
a new class in there we'll call this one
yeah Java there we go oops Java and
under Java we want to go ahead and OH
create some of the similar stuff and
then I want to go back to my student I
took out the main and student just
because I don't want it to run the main
in there and in here we're gonna have
system out we're gonna have instead of
studying computers focus on Java which
is what we're doing right now and maybe
we'll call this classroom and then we
can come down here and we have our P
equals new computers well instead of new
computers we want our Java and it's
going to be a Java object and we need to
put our extends in up here extends in
this case we came from computers so
there's our initial thing and then we
have our last print in here
of course if we run this now we'll see
that it should if I did everything
correctly come up and say enrolled and
simply learn studying computers focus on
Java and we have the enrolled which is
the parent to computers and then we have
under computers well we have student
than computers and then Java and so each
one of these classes just cascades all
the way down and this is your multi
level from your class a to class B to
class C and if you have multi-level
inheritance we can also have a
hierarchical inheritance where your
parent-child relationship the only
difference is here multiple child
classes inherit from one parent class
and that is pretty moving to another
class here if you remember quickly we
had student computers maybe from student
will have set of computers will have
project management project management
your studying your Idol and all your
other classes in there for cascade and
for doing agile programming and in here
we can do that it's just the same as we
did before we just have a second child
coming in from here and so this would go
ahead and extend extends stems student
and of course whatever subcategory you
have one in here for running this and so
for here we'd have like our void studies
in this case instead of studying
computers we're studying project
management project management one of the
other wonderful classes it is taught
from the simply learn team and run that
and you can see right here we have
computers whoops course instead of
computers I meant to do object
management there we go
we have to also initiate it as a new
and then when we run here we can see
this
we're enrolled in simply learn and we're
studying project management and then
finally there is the hybrid the name
itself explains it to us
the hybrid inheritance can be a
combination of any of the three types of
inheritance supported in Java and so
maybe we already saw that because we
have our a and our B if we flip back on
over to our Eclipse we have our student
our student now has a computers project
management so there's our hierarchical
and then they're mixed because we also
have the Java which is an extension of
the computer and so we have multiple
layers there so one of the issues that
comes up with inheritance in classes is
what they call the diamond problem and
in the diamond problem the java
programming language does not support
multiple inheritance as it ends up with
serious ambiguity and that is where we
have d which inherits from both B and C
which might both inherit from a this is
the diamond factor because as you start
tracking your supers going up which one
are you actually looking at B or C or a
and that's why they call this a diamond
problem it comes up more than you would
think you get very complicated
structures and you realize oh I need to
have both sets of instructions come down
to whatever I'm working on and you can
see where that can become a problem let
us take a look at is a relation and has
a relation now these I mean they're
vocabulary but they're more of a concept
understanding how things fit together
and so we talked about is a relation
when a class inherits methods and
members from a different class than the
relationship is said to be is a relation
examples orange is a fruit and oh let's
just jump back on over here and we'll
make a new class
and we'll call this class customer so
we're gonna have our customers oops
there we go if I can remember how to
type so we have a class customer and we
I've gotten ahead and our team in the
back when it hadn't prepped this for us
let's just take a quick look though we
got public string name so it's accessed
publicly if you leave this out a lot of
matically be be public because that's
the default and then we have our
customer and the string which is a name
and a string as a city and then when you
do a customer and you send it the name
of the city it will do this name equals
name in this city equals city we could
have easily done this private we have a
call into it to create it so it wouldn't
really matter too much whether we did it
private or public I would actually be
more likely to do it private
and for this example we'll go ahead and
create a another class and we'll call
this store will have our store class we
have customers and we have a store and
then we'll go ahead and set up in here
and this time we did do a private we're
gonna create a list of customer
customers and then the store list coming
down and then this customer customers
and public list customers a quick look
at this is we did make this one private
which is nice because now it can't be
accessed externally except from store
and then the store has the public list
customers so we can send it a list of
customers and then it go ahead and and
returns the customers from that list and
then when we add it to the store
it sets the customers in the store this
dot customer is equals customers one of
the reasons we have the error lines in
years I haven't compiled it so it
doesn't see that customers are part of
our package and we'll get to that in
just a moment here
and then let's go ahead and create
another class we'll call this is a
relation since that's what we're working
on and here there is a relation set up
and we're just going to put this as the
main so you have your main in there and
then we went ahead and prepared a series
of customers and we'll just call it
customers c1 equals a new customer
customer c2 equals a new customer and
we're just creating a list here that's
all we're doing and if we're gonna have
a list then we need to go ahead and
create a list of customers and we'll
just do that it with a simple list set
up and and we got to add those customers
in to the list so let's go ahead and do
that so breaking this down we have a
customer one which is raju bangalore
shiva hyper bad such in Mumbai and so on
and then we just created a list of
customers a new array of lists and we
add in each of those customers so now we
have a nice list of all our different
customers in here and then we want to go
ahead and create our store it will put
it in store and it'll be a fruit
smoothies franchise I put down fruit
smoothies French um maybe that's not a
good abbreviation you may think it's a
French instead of franchise there'll be
a new store and then we have our new
store which is in this case we're gonna
put in that new store customers and if
you remember we went back here into
store let me just flip back on over
there it's gonna take that list of
customers and put that into this
customer so now the private list is
going to equal that list of customers
and then of course we can come in here
and we do public list it's going to
return that list of customers so we have
public assets here and this store you
can add public at the beginning we'll go
ahead and do that just to make it clear
is it public or is what's going to run
on there and let's go back into our is a
relation
and hoops the back to store I'm gonna go
ahead and change this to customer list
so here's our list customer list and
it's going to return the customers from
this selection from our private variable
as we come into here we can come down
here and we'll go ahead and put that in
there we'll do a loop on this we'll have
a list customer and we're gonna create a
list of our customers from our root
smoothies franchise and we'll get the
customer list from there and then for a
customer and in the for customer CST in
customer we're gonna go ahead just print
that name out there now at this point if
you have an error showing up here under
lists and also underneath ArrayList
depending on how you did your install
you might have to go ahead and import
those your array list from your Java
utility not a big deal and then once we
go ahead and we have this all set up
you'll see here the compiler goes
through and then we have the name of the
customer a city and then it just lists
the customers going down here
so when we talk about our relationship
of our fruit smoothies franchise and
customers the customers they are
relationship directly to the French
smoothies franchise now the second idea
is it has a relation and let's go ahead
and take a look at that and see how that
differs and we'll go ahead and create a
oh it's he we had customers so let's do
and we'll call this one but doing the
smoothie so we'll have flavors or
favorite will do favorite flavors
favorite flavors for a class very
strange class and the C in favorite
flavors will go ahead and give it a
couple things to look at we'll have a
private string and a name and then we'll
have a public string get flavor there we
go and that's just going to return
return we'll just have that return the
name of the flavor there we go and then
we want to go ahead and create one more
class and this class will call has a
relation and I'm hoping you're guessing
where we're going with this let's go and
put some code in here to make it work
yeah let's go back to our favorite
flavors and put in a constructor so that
we can load the flavors and then in
return this name so we can return the
flavors I'll go back into has a relation
and let's just create a customer we'll
call it cust our new customer is Tobey
Marshall from Mumbai and our favorite
flavors are strawberry banana and peanut
butter don't know it's a strange
concoction
and then we run a print line we're gonna
print the customer name from customers
and the flavors get flavor and so
when we're looking at this what I want
you to be aware of is that neither the
flavors nor the customer are in the same
class they're not it's not an actual
relationship but they have a
relationship because we have Toby who
happens to like strawberry and peanut
butter and if you remember just a quick
note we were looking at the diamond
problem you can create a class that then
has these two subclasses in and that's
how you go around the diamond problem is
you don't inherit but you create classes
inside the class you're working with so
entering a Q&A session we certainly at
simply learned WW simply learn calm have
a nice community along with our bulletin
boards for answering questions from our
experts
we'll take just a few moments to answer
questions from the teacher or whoever's
proctoring this thank you for joining us
as simply learned for more information
please visit